[Music]
Los Angeles everybody want to be star
you have to be the best and never give
up then I get up on stage in front of
people don't like it think about is but
if they laugh at me you man you're
fearless I want to feel that too
I don't care I'll do it you know me with
both how this drink yeah I guess we do
ha ha I will be fine I will Charlotte
watch out here we go just be or not to
be it's not gonna happen for you
not in a million years but after a lot
it's a town Greg they don't want me wish
we could just make our own movie a great
idea so there's this guy Johnny a true
American Hero to be played by me he has
it all
good luck make friends and also maybe
Johnny is vampire alleyway that's right
well why are we just shooting the real
le because it's real Hollywood movie no
yeah ok action I did not hit her I did
not a high mark but the foot doesn't
work if you're looking at the camera and
then this big girl
anything for my team says he betrayed
him and then this got Johnny you go
crazy
nobody respect my business do I fill it
I do this whole movie for you Greg why
you God sandy this is great this real
acting we're gonna ride around with the
dress maybe do it before you shoot
yourself in the head employer brings out
I disagree I'm gonna make this thing we
are going to go together
[Music]
honey this is not necessarily very
necessary that I need to show my house
to sell this movie I think you're aiming
uh and why I am just does obscene why'd
he having sex with her belly button he
knows where her vagina is right hi doggy
[Music]